Sometimes things are just meant to be.
No wifi on this flight put me in a mindset.
Not having a whole lot of work left to do
put me in a mindset.
This time, this moment, put me in a mindset
and the mindset is real simple.
I was able to read so many of your
emails and your DM's right now. So many.
So many people coming from
so many different backgrounds.
So many different ages, heritages, religions, experiences
and I'm sitting here just saying to myself,
"My God, everybody's got something."
Everybody's sitting right now
as they're watching this video
and they've got something that they're dwelling about.
Something that's pulling them down,
something that's holding them back.
Something that happened a long time ago,
or something that's going on right now.
It just feels so intense for me right this second.
It feels really, really hard core for me.
Just consuming all this content. All these questions.
And I'm in this circumstance where people
want to ask me and I feel so gifted about it.
I don't know if I'm up to the task or not every time,
but I know my intent is.
And I know I've desperately wanted to just make this video and let everybody know
that everybody's got something.
So many if you look around. Look at all those people
and you think they've got it better
and default into thinking somebody's got
a little more privilege, a little better.
Somewhere along the line I heard somebody say,
"All of us are born  with a gift and a curse."
Right. Either we have too much or we have too little.
And I get that.
I get that and I think about
it's not where you start,  it's where you finish.
I see things that people don't see.
Like people that are gifted with privilege
and it cripples them and it fucks them from the get
and they've lost before they've started
and obviously people that are born with so little
and such different difficult circumstances.
Everybody's got something
and it's always going to be like that
and I just want people to know that.
If we could just all deploy a little more empathy
and realize that it just makes it
a little bit easier for you to deal with yours.
It's not misery loves company,
it's actually completely the reverse.
It's wishing and wanting for everybody to win and realizing none of that comes at your expense.
It's wishing and wanting that people can navigate through the maze of the circumstances they were dealt.
The hand they were given.
It's wishing that they are surrounded by
the people that can help them, or
they can consume something, whether it's
a song, or a poem or a book or a movie,
or a video like this that switches their mindset.
That inspires them,
galvanizes them, makes them realize they have no choice but to do it for themselves.
Nobody's going to do it for you.
There's people out there rooting for you,
there's people out there cheering for you.
Your mom is cheering for you sometimes.
My mother is rooting for you because she is the kindest.
But just understanding that everybody's got something -
liberates everything.
And allows you to put that piece of
the equation on the shelf, tucked away.
It's a non-variable because we've all got something.
That's how this fucking game is dealt.
Once you realize that,
you stop worrying about everybody else.
You know why?
You stop worrying about everybody else because:
A: you realize they've got something.
B: you don't give a fuck about their opinion -
cause they've got something.
Everybody's got something. Everybody.
Everybody's got the trash. Everybody's got the pain.
It puts us all in one footing.
They come in different shapes and sizes.
But to that fucking person, it's theirs.
So please my friends, please
understand that everybody has something.
Everybody's got their fucking pain.
Now it's an even playing field.
Deploy empathy and deploy confidence in yourself,
cause nobody's judgement on you means shit,
cause they've got something to.
Do you know why I roll with peace?
Or as close to as it gets?
Cause I just know that truth.
That truth I put on a fucking pedestal.
It's been in me the whole time and it took
this circumstance and this flight
to help me articulate it a little bit.
Everybody's got something, so I feel bad for them
and I don't value them.
Nobody's opinion of me matters more than myself
and I don't judge anybody, cause
I don't know their fucking reality,
cause everybody's got something. EVERYBODY!